the kids caught in kimye's war as kanye
goes after kim and her mom
i have an opinion
last night yay posted that he's addicted
to porn and wants to shield his
daughters from it quote don't let chris
make you do playboy like she made kylie
and kim do pornography destroyed my
family you're doing amazing
that seemingly prompted kim to send a
series of texts which he posted and
deleted
kim can you please stop yay no we need
to talk in person kim forwarded this
message she says is from her mom tell
him to please stop mentioning my name
i'm almost 67 years old and i don't
always feel great and this stresses me
to no end no matter what he's saying
you you always protect him as hard as it
can be sometimes i do try to ignore it
and just try to do whatever's best for
the kids
it's been a fight for when my kids go to
school and we started
our own school
yay also posted a pic of these students
first day at his academy and a text to
kim suggesting their kid split time
between two different schools caption
this is co-parenting
[Music]